hi I'm Toby and welcome back today I'd
like to show you through the report card
of none other than the famous Albert
Einstein I have his grades here from the
end of high school as well as during his
time at University and I'd like to take
a bit of a look through with you to see
what Einstein was really like as a
student there's a bit of a myth that
goes around that Einstein was really bad
at math and failed that at school but
from having a look at his grades we will
see that Einstein was actually a pretty
good student although his grades aren't
perfect and his time as a student wasn't
without struggle looking at Einsteins
grades reveals interesting information
about his life his teachers and what was
going on in physics at the time as well
as Einsteins school and university
grades I also have how his grades
compared to his classmates at the time
and also the grades of his first wife
who he met while studying at university
so with that let's have a look just so
we know the time line here when Einstein
was 16 and 1/2 in 1895 he actually tried
to get into the ETH University in Zurich
Switzerland but he failed the entrance
exam the normal age that you have to be
to even take the entrance exam is 18 so
he was trying to get in early the
entrance exam had a scientific section
which Einstein apparently did quite well
on as well as a general section which
was his downfall apparently he got quite
low grades in the linguistics questions
after that disappointment Einstein
enrolls in the Argonne School which is a
secondary school near Zurich in
Switzerland where he will continue his
education and graduating from this
school would allow him to be directly
admitted to ETH without having to do the
entrance exam again so this first
document I have here is Einsteins final
grades from his year at the our Gow
school her Albert Einstein from whom
which is the town in Germany that he was
from born on the 14th of March
1879 that's Pi Day the 14th of March
attended the Canton school in Argyle
you might have noticed this is all in
German so I'm giving you a bit of a
translation although I don't speak
German myself these are the subjects
that he took and his grade now a grade
of 6 is the highest one obtainable it
would mean very good and a grade of 1
would be very poor so we can see he's
taken German language and Latricia
French English Italian history geography
algebra he's got a 6 there geometry
including trigonometry and analytic
geometry a 6 as well the highest score
descriptive geometry physics again a 6
so he looks like a pretty good student
here at those subjects chemistry a
little bit lower a 5 Natural History art
drawing and technical drawing so his
lowest grade here from when he was
leaving school would have been French at
only a 3 out of 6 but is clearly a very
good student at the Scientifics here
math and physics subjects and there we
go he graduates from the school in
October 1896 allowing him to go straight
to ETH and this here is his grade record
from his whole time there at University
Albert Einstein on the front of the
grade record here this is referring to
the entrance exam and ordinarily they
would write your entrance scores here
but since he was able to have direct
entry from school that is empty and we
just have his admission date October
1896 and his exit date of August 1900
thus would be the grades from his first
semester 1896 to 1897 we have the
subject the teacher the grade that
Einstein received and again one is the
lowest grade and six is the highest
grade then we have a column for notes or
remarks their translations are
differential and integral calculus by
Hurwitz analytical geometry descriptive
geometry mechanics with exercises
determinants and projective geometry
and it looks like he's done fairly well
at his subjects although no sixes here
so the grades aren't perfect over to the
next semester we have differential
calculus and then physics by Weber or
maybe vibha if it's German now
Weber is a teacher of Einsteins worth
mentioning because he made quite an
impact on Einstein during his time there
after Einstein initially failed the
entrance exam when he was only 16
it was Weber who invited Einstein to sit
in on his lectures while he was
attending the school nearby
but during Einstein's time as a student
with him Weber seems to have turned on
Einstein and they ended with a very poor
relationship Einstein thought that
Weavers physics lectures were actually a
bit old fashioned and out-of-date
around this time I believe that
physicists were starting to accept
Maxwell's laws and incorporate that into
their teaching except for Weber who
didn't include Maxwell's laws at all so
Einstein didn't really have much respect
for Weber and did a lot of his own self
learning to learn some of these things
like Mexico's laws and other current
work at the time there was another
professor that Einstein also didn't get
along with who will encounter on the
next page but for now let's look at the
rest of these subjects we've got
mechanics projective geometry again and
then another familiar name Minkowski
down here this is geometry of numbers
and it's interesting that Minkowski was
a former teacher of Einstein you may
have encountered the Mankowski name when
reading about some of own Stein's worth
maybe about general relativity because
Minkowski space-time and a few other
things under this name are quite
important mathematical ideas there so
Minkowski actually later on in life
ended up helping with the mathematics of
Einstein's theory that at this time in
Kowski was his teacher although and this
is a bit of a trend Einstein actually
skipped a lot of minkowski's lectures
like II did with Lieber and others
Einstein didn't think that he would
derive much value from attending the
lectures and would rather just study on
his own we have some more classes from
an cows
get down here we've got function theory
and potential theory we'll go to the
next semester and this is where things
get a little bit spicy if we zoom in
down here we will see the lowest grade
that we're going to see in this record
and that is intro to the practice of
physics it would appear that this is a
lab course and it was taught by
Professor John Pinette Einstein very
seldom showed up to this practical
course and so Pinay gave him the lowest
possible grade of a 1 and he wrote this
note up here which says March 1899
reprimand from the director on account
of lack of diligence in the physics
practicum
so really Einstein was penalized for not
showing up enough to this class his
other grades on this semester include a
6 from Weber in electro technical
laboratorium a 5 from Weber in
scientific work in physics lab and a
four and a half down here for something
that translates as geographic location
but maybe it's got something to do with
geometry I'm not sure I should mention
that this Weber I've been talking about
is not the same Weber that
electromagnetic flux is named after that
is wilheim Weber and this professor here
is a Heinrich Weaver on our last
semester here we have partial
differential equations AC systems and AC
motors systems of absolute electrical
measurements scientific work in the
physics lab where he's got a 6 and a 5
so fairly high grades intro to
alternating current and applications of
analytical mechanics it's not clear to
me if the dashes indicate that he didn't
take the course or if the course just
didn't have an exam because there are
many sources that say Minkowski was a
former teacher of Einstein but all I'm
seeing is a lot of dashes next to his
name this last page is his certificate
of departure and seems to be a summary
of all of his courses and grades
indicating that he graduated with his
diploma as specialist teacher in
mathematic direction granted by the
Swiss school council in July 28 1901 and
the fact that Einstein didn't show up to
a lot of his classes may be a bit of a
surprise to you it has said that
Einstein could not easily bring himself
to study what did not interest him and
most of his time he spent on his own and
joyful exploration of the wonders of
science
Einstein said in his autobiography that
one had to cram all this stuff into
one's mind for the examinations whither
one liked it or not this coercion had
such a deterring effect upon him that he
says after I had passed the examination
I found the consideration of any
scientific problems distasteful to me
for an entire year now that is a sadly
relatable quote I find that the process
of being tested on subjects drains your
interest in that subject so much that
you don't even want to look at it and it
no longer brings you joy I guess we're
lucky that Einstein didn't just quit
physics there and did seem to refined
his joy and his desire to work on
difficult problems the next paper I want
to show is a document from halfway
through the degree and it shows the
classmates at Einstein hat it's a pretty
small class is just five of them and
we've got Einstein here and we can see
that halfway through his degree if this
is the average column that he was the
highest average student so he was top of
his class there is one notable classmate
of Einsteins down here Grossman and he
is notable because he was a good friend
of Einstein's and actually he is who
allowed ironstone to be able to skip so
many classes because Einstein would
study from Crossman's notes before the
exams Einstein was very grateful to
Grossman and he said that he was a very
diligent student who took very good
notes it's kind of tragic for him that
Einstein the guy who was stealing his
notes is the only one in the class who
scored higher than him after graduation
the other four students and the
except for Einstein went on to get
assistant positions in the university
doing physics Einstein however was not
able to get such a position but he did
try because he wanted to continue his
career in physics his tactic of copying
Grossman's notes came back to bite him
because he had such a poor relationship
with many of his teachers that none of
them wanted to take iron stain on as
their assistant einstein considered it
to be Weber who was conspiring everyone
against him
and Einstein even wrote letters out to
many physicists across Europe to try and
get them to take him on but he had no
success his one salvation turned out to
be Grossman in the end as Grossman's dad
was able to get Einstein his job at the
Patent Office after a while I even read
that because of Einstein's mastery of
Maxwell's laws the painted officer was
happy to hire him but I guess he really
had Grossman to thank for a lot of that
now there's one more document that I'd
like to take a look at and that is the
great history of Mileva Maric who was
Einstein's first wife and she actually
met Einstein while studying at ETH she
was in the same class at the start she
also was admitted in October 1896 and
was studying the same subjects although
she spent a year in the middle studying
at the University of Heidelberg this is
the summary of her grades you can see
they're actually pretty good we've got a
five and something to do with the
geometry she's done differential and
integral calculus she has survived
Bernays practical physics course and
this is the one where Einstein got a 1
that she managed to get a 5 sadly
however she did not graduate because she
failed her final exam and then shortly
after became pregnant with Einsteins
child she did make one more attempt to
pass the final exam but wasn't
successful and then moved away with
Einstein to support him in his work I
thought it would be worth making a note
about her because she also was quite
important to Einsteins
at ETH and she is the one who he did a
lot of that self-study with she was the
one who he shared reading about
Maxwell's laws worth and just exploring
their joy of physics together so that's
all I wanted to show you today if
there's any takeaway message it's that
einstein did score pretty high grades as
a student but that time was not without
struggle einstein knows what it's like
to not get along with your professors
and to feel like the school system is
beating your interest out of you i would
say it's not a good idea to employ
einstein strategy of not going to
lectures and just copying someone else's
notes because although he passed it did
really come to hurt him when he tried to
get a job later on and i think that
still applies to university now you want
to be on good terms with people that are
in your field whether it's for reference
letters or to just have good
relationships in academia so thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time this
video was made possible by you my
viewers through your support on patreon
thank you special mention to today's
patron cat of the day Brandon
[Music]